[Music]
foreign
so in the last few lectures I've been
showing you how to numerically compute
the derivative of a function f of x or F
of T and in this video I'm going to show
you how to do the opposite how to do
numerical integration so to find the
area under the curve of a function
and this can be a little confusing this
terminology because numerical
integration actually means two different
things there is numerically integrating
an ordinary differential equation to
find a trajectory through phase space
that's one interpretation that I'll talk
about soon probably in the next lecture
but this lecture when I see numerical
integration I literally mean numerically
Computing the definite integral which is
the area under a function from point A
to point B okay so we're going to find
the area under this function using kind
of numerical uh numerical methods
and just like before we're
going to take kind of the the Riemann
integral definition that you would take
the limit as Delta X goes to zero where
these little rectangles become
infinitesimal that's the Riemann
integral and we're not going to take
that limit and we're going to see what
happens for a finite width area
approximation
so just some notation we're going to
assume that our data is defined at
points x 0 x 1 x 2 dot dot dot you know
X3
in this case all the way up to
um let's say x
x n x Big N I'm going to similarly
Define my data points maybe I'll make
these pink uh you know F 0 f 1 f 2
F3 dot dot dot f n where specifically
I'm defining that you know whatever f k
for whatever K value here f
K is just F evaluated at X K F K this
data point uh that I'm using the
subscript K that just means FK equals my
function evaluated at this point x k
so F1 F 0 equals f of x naught F1 is f
evaluated at X1 and so on and so forth
good
um and I'm also finally going to assume
that this left point is a point I'm
going to call it kind of like a that's
the left bound of my integration my
right point is some point B that's the
right point of my integration and I
clearly have n of these little steps
between A and B because this is Big N
there's n of these little steps and I'm
going to assume for now that these are
spaced at a constant
um a constant Delta X you don't have to
assume that but that's going to make our
lives easier for now is to assume that
these are evenly spaced we'll relax that
in a minute
uh so maybe I'll change to Orange
so n is the number of Rec of uh whatever
like rectangles or data points of a
number of
um of points
and so Delta X is B minus a divided by
Big N that's kind of the width
uh between each of these data points
okay that's my like Delta X
and so the absolute simplest thing we
could do is remember the Riemann
integral basically chops this up into
like rectangles that are either uh kind
of you know at height F0 F1 F2 times
width Delta X it chops this into a bunch
of rectangles and then takes the limit
as that rectangle width goes to zero
that's how the Riemann integral is
defined
and so I think I'll just actually write
this out so the the normal way to do
this integral from A to B
of f of x DX
is equal to typically we say it's the
limit as either Delta X goes to zero or
as n the number of Divisions goes to
Infinity I'll just say limit is n
goes to Infinity doesn't matter also the
same as Delta X going to zero they're
the same thing
of the sum
from uh k equals one
to n
of the width the height of these
rectangles times the width of these
rectangles so I'm literally just going
to
um
uh how do I want to draw this
um I guess what you would do is you
could
my formula that I'm going to use that
I'm going to derive is for the
right-handed rectangle Rule and there's
many ways of doing this so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say that
this is approximately equal to the area
of this rectangle here
plus the area of this rectangle here
plus the area of this rectangle this
rectangle this rectangle and so on and
so forth so we're we're literally going
to break this up into a bunch of
rectangles and we're going to compute
the area of all of these rectangles
and we're going to add these up and
that's going to be our Riemann integral
and then we're going to take the limit
as Delta X goes to 0 or if you like as I
have infinitely many points between A
and B okay and so uh essentially what
we're looking at
is uh at a given k at k equals one two
three four so the first rectangle is k1
the second rectangle is K2 and so on and
so forth
so I'm going to take the height is going
to be f
of
a
Plus
uh K Delta X
so if K is 1 then it's a plus K Delta X
is my x one point so that's F of that
point
that's this height of this rectangle
here
times
Delta X okay this is literally the uh
the Riemann integral approximation of
the area under this uh this blue curve
from point A to point B so I'm taking
the height of f
evaluate it at you know x equals a plus
K Delta X so for K1 for the first K
that's at height F of X1 that's my first
height of my first rectangle at K2 it
would be a plus 2 Delta X is f of x 2
which is the second rectangle height and
so on and so forth so I add up all of
those rectangles and the area of each
rectangle is its height here times its
width here and you would normally take
the limit as n goes to infinity and
Delta X goes to zero and this will be
the exact integral
so if instead
of
um instead of taking this limit as n
goes to Infinity what if I didn't what
if I just dropped this and I take this
finite sum for finite Delta X so that's
what we're going to be talking about
today how does the error scale with that
you know what are the properties does it
work does it not work things like that
and I'll take one more step to simplify
a plus K Delta X is just the height of
my rectangle at that point so this
equals limit as n goes to Infinity sum
of k equals 1 to n f of let's say X
k
Delta X and this is the right handed or
right-sided I don't know exactly what
everyone calls it these days but
basically you have this little
rectangular interval with these two
points and you could use the value at
the right hand side this this you know
X1 or you could use the value at the
left hand side this little X zero so
this is what I'm going to call the right
sided
the right-sided Riemann interval or the
right-sided rectangle rule rectangle
approximation of the integral now if I'm
actually taking an honest to goodness
limit here technically this will also
equal the limit uh as n goes to Infinity
the sum of k equals 0 to n minus 1. of f
of x k
Delta X where now all I've changed is
the limits of my summation and so now
instead of using the instead of making
the height of my rectangle based on the
right data point X1 I'm making it based
on the left data point x0 so I'm not
really sure I can draw this very cleanly
but the left-handed integral rule would
be you know using this area of the left
side of the integral and so they're
slightly different so one of them is
going to over predict on positive slopes
and under predict on negative slopes the
other one is going to do the opposite
okay and this is called the left
cited
rectangle
um good and I'll just maybe draw a teeny
little picture here so like literally if
I have
um you know this little piece of the
curve here the left-sided integral is
going to use the left point
to approximate the area okay like this
and the right-sided rectangle rule same
exact curve same exact curve the
right-handed rectangle rule is going to
use the value at the the rightmost point
to approximate the area okay maybe I'll
draw it like this
and so like I said if I have a positive
slope of my function the left-sided
rectangle is going to under predict it's
going to miss all of this region here so
this is missing and the right-sided rule
uh the left the right-sided rule is
going to over predict it's going to
actually overestimate all of this stuff
here so you can now already see where
the error is going to come from it's
going to come from the first derivative
of f
okay good
[Music]
for now that's actually what I wanted to
show you
um
what I'm going to claim is that now you
can actually take this expression and
you can work out what the error in the
approximation is if I don't take the
limit as Delta X goes to zero
um
so how do I want to how do I want to say
this
um
so these are kind of like
the the finite difference derivatives we
did the forward difference and the
backward difference these are kind of
like the forward difference and the
backwards difference but for numerical
integration and like in differentiation
those were those had the most error and
the worst scaling these also have the
most error and the worst scaling so
clearly you can kind of already start to
see that there is a better alternative
that instead of using
um you know the left point or the right
Point why don't I use both points so an
even better approach would be let's say
I have you know these
two points uh here why don't I actually
take the area
to be this little trapezoid here so I
now have this area of this trapezoid so
this is going to be called the trapezoid
rule so there's the right rectangle the
left rectangle and then the trapezoid
rule which I'll write out here so the
trapezoid trapezoidal
trapezoidal integration
and this is actually pretty easy it's
literally just the average of
left-handed and right-handed so it's
literally
equals one half
uh you know right-sided plus left-sided
integrals okay pretty easy and you could
numerically compute that by instead of
just taking you know the area using the
left point or the right point you
basically average those points and use
the area based on the average value
that's equivalent to the the trapezoidal
integration is to average average those
values okay
um good and so this is actually going to
have even better error this is kind of
like the central difference so this is
kind of like uh you know backwards
difference forward difference Central
difference but for integration okay so
we're using uh more information here and
getting a better a better approximation
um and in Matlab and python this is
literally like the Trap Z command
um so this is the
trap Z command for for a trapezoidal you
know if I add data X and data F I would
literally type in X comma F and it would
uh it would compute this and notice that
none of these actually have to have a
constant fixed Delta X like all of these
would be totally valid for the X you
know some of these X to be fat and some
of these X to be skinny it would be
totally fine if you know I sampled my uh
my function
so that you know maybe I sample it
really wide and then fine and then wide
like this that's totally fine I can
still approximate the error or sorry the
uh the area
using these little rectangles or
trapezoids between these points so if I
liked I could still build a trapezoid
you know between these points and these
points and this point and I can do kind
of the trapezoidal integration and
approximate the area you know if even if
I have
some points more finely represented than
others that's totally fine so the Delta
X spacing doesn't have to be uniform for
any of these algorithms it's pretty easy
for it not to be
um and you'll notice actually that the
trapezoidal integration is going to be
exact except for there being this second
derivative curvature here so the
trapezoidal rule just like these guys
overshot or under shot the value
depending on the slope
the trapezoidal integration error is
coming from the second derivative from
the curvature so regions that are
approximately linear are almost perfect
and you only miss this part here because
of the curvature this is the error do
to curvature and remember curvature of a
function is f double Prime okay the F
double Prime when F double Prime is
large the trapezoidal integration is not
going to do well so it's not going to do
well if I um
like if I zoom in uh you know if I have
something that looks like that that has
a lot of curvature my trapezoidal
integration is going to miss
this is all kind of error here this is
all missing
uh Missing
from Trap
Z okay now we can compute the error of
each of these schemes using kind of the
same basic idea that we did for finite
derivatives we would basically write out
a Taylor series we would appropriately
plug them into the right places of these
these different
um
these different terms and we would
basically find so I might do a lecture
on that I might not I actually have some
old lectures from uh you know when I
taught this about 10 years ago so I
might put a link to that because I think
that's actually a pretty concise version
of how to actually compute all of the
error of these numerical Integrations
I'm not super duper conserved with
concerned with like deriving all the
Taylor series error for these it's
probably like a homework assignment for
you all
but the upshot
is that if I remember correctly
left-sided and right-sided
for every little rectangle
they have an error that is proportional
to Delta x squared so let me just write
that out so these each
have what I'm going to call a local
error
of proportional to Delta x squared
meaning for every single little box they
have an error of Delta x squared and
again this comes from the Taylor series
um you know like the Taylor series
approximation local error of Delta x
squared
but because I'm adding up
approximately you know
one over n I'm adding this up n times
and N scales like 1 over Delta X
this accumulates a bunch of times I'm
adding up a bunch of these Delta X
squareds and I'm adding up 1 over Delta
X of them so kind of the global or total
error Global or total
integration error over this entire area
scales like Delta X which is actually
pretty bad that's not a good that's not
a good error okay so that means again if
I want my error to be 10 times smaller I
have to decrease my Delta X by a factor
of 10. okay so this is again just like
forward difference and backwards
difference for derivatives uh the the
total error scales linearly with Delta x
with the increment okay the trapezoidal
integration if I remember correctly and
I could be wrong so double check this
you can Google you know trapezoidal
integration error scaling but I'm pretty
sure
that this is local
local error of Delta X cubed which I
think means we have a total error
of Delta x squared and my intuition the
reason I feel like this is because again
the error here was proportional to a
first derivative you know the slope of f
if the slope is positive it behaved one
way if the slope is negative it behaved
another way whereas the
trapezoidal integration rule is a
function of the curvature and so if I
did a Taylor series expansion the first
derivative and the curvature those would
be one delta T apart in the Taylor
series and so I'm assuming this is or
one sorry one Delta X and so I'm
assuming that this has one Delta X
better error properties than these kind
of like this is a central difference and
these are forward and backward
difference again I think that this uh
this would hold I'm not 100 sure but I'm
pretty sure that's true
um and again that's way way better that
means if I want a better error by a fact
you know if I decrease my Delta X by a
factor of 10 this actually gets 100
times better total integration error
while this only gets 10 times better
good what else do I want to tell you
um
there's a really powerful method called
Simpsons rule um Simpson's rule is
probably the best easy numerical
integration scheme uh Simpsons Simpsons
rule
and essentially if you like under the
hood of Simpson's rule this works if you
have three data points so if I have some
uh you know I've got three data points
let's say you know f
um
I'm just going to use f f 0 F1 F2 and I
want to find the area you know the area
under this thing and of course you can
shift this to F K F K plus Y and F K
plus 2 or you know F K minus 1 F K F K
plus one you can you can Center this
wherever you like but I'm just these are
easier indices for me to work with
Simpson's rule says that the integral
from X naught to x two from uh here to
here is going to equal of f of x DX
is going to equal okay so it's Delta X
over 3
times F 0
plus 4 F1
plus F 2. so this is some weird
combination that you would get from
Taylor series expansion presumably
yes Delta x to the fifth
or 90
times the
the you know the max fourth derivative
of x in this region okay so this is
really good actually so this means that
locally at every little local width
rectangle here this has Delta x to the
fifth local error it's way better than
either of these which means it's local
error so this is local error
Delta x to the fifth which means it has
a total error of Delta x to the fourth
so it blows both of these out of the
water
and you'll find in in the next few
lectures just like uh I had a forward
difference backward different Central
difference for derivatives and I've got
right sided rectangle left-sided
rectangle trapezoidal
um difference for derivatives this is
basically a higher order scheme you can
essentially think of this as building a
spline a cubic spline interpolation
through these points and then
analytically integrating that cubic
spline I believe that's what Simpson's
rule does and it pushes that Taylor
series error way way out to order Delta
x to the fifth locally and this is
actually kind of numerically going to be
the analog of a fourth order runga Kata
scheme in uh numerical uh integration of
ordinary differential equations that's a
teaser for for a future lecture
okay so this was an overwhelming amount
but basically I presented you with four
types of integration uh left and right
rectangle rules are kind of my basic
rectangular Riemann integrals they have
crappy error scaling but sometimes
that's good enough you know quick and
dirty if you want to do better than that
you can do trapezoidal integration which
geometrically gets you more of this area
by just averaging these two and it also
has better error error scaling kind of
like the central difference had better
error scaling and if you really need a
lot better error you can do something
fancy like assume that there's some
cubic spline between these points fit
that integrated analytically and use
Simpson's rule which is actually very
simple to write down numerically and
it's got way way way better numerical uh
numerical accuracy scaling with with
Delta X
so I think what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to erase everything and then
I'm just going to you know code this up
a little bit in in Python and Matlab and
we'll just get a little feeling for for
how these errors scale and things like
that
um yeah and I'm gonna I'm telling you
what these errors are based on a Taylor
series but I haven't actually shown you
I think what I would do here is I would
say F of
you know X Plus Delta X or f of x minus
Delta X and I'd expand those out and I'd
use the Taylor series and I'd get
something that told me what these errors
were and I do the same thing for
trapezoid and you can do the same thing
for Simpsons rule that's you know that
should be old hat for you right now and
if you really want to understand this
you can definitely you know do that on
pencil and paper as a homework example
okay I'm going to erase and then we'll
do some coding all right one second
okay so I've given myself a little room
to work here and I've erased all of the
formulas because I don't think that's
going to be super duper helpful you can
you know Intuit how to compute the left
and right rectangle Rule and average
them for the trapezoid rule
I've left these pictures because these
kind of show what we're doing and what
we're going to do now is actually just
build a little function like sine of X
and integrate this from 0 to 10. so the
the exact value is something like 1.8391
or it's approximately exact this is very
accurate
um and then we're going to integrate it
using these different techniques to see
kind of what the error accuracy is okay
so we are going to Define our A and B
limits as 0 and 10 and we're going to
start with a
a really fine Delta X of 0.01 that's
presumably going to be for plotting so I
want to plot this thing on a really
really fine domain so you can see like
the crisp clean sine wave this is uh
that's this this f means fine and so I'm
going to you know plot
um
I changed F to Y here so this is this is
y f not f f whatever it doesn't matter
you can call this y of X it doesn't
matter so we're integrating y of X here
and so we're going to plot that find
function and now I'm defining a coarse
Delta X of 0.5 that's actually massive
that's a really big Delta X for for a
sine function and
um and this is some plotting commands to
kind of show pictorially uh what I've
drawn here which is
using the left rectangle rule I believe
so the left Point here you use that left
area
to create this kind of Step function and
the area under the step function is
going to be our approximation to the
area of the true sine wave in in Orange
and so again you can see pretty clearly
that the left integral rule is going to
under predict these triangles when the
slope is positive it's going to over
predict these triangles when the slope
is negative
um yeah we already saw that it's pretty
clear from this and similarly if I use
the other rectangle rule it would do the
exact opposite it would be over
predicting positive slopes and
underpredicting negative slopes and if I
average them in this this trapezoid rule
it's going to do a much better job of
not underpredicting or overpredicting
those slopes and it's only going to be
bad when I have high curvature
okay so now we can actually
um
go through and compute the left
rectangle rule area the right rectangle
rule area and the trapezoidal rule so
this is literally just a for Loop that's
going through all of these data points
and it's either using
um you know the Y value on the left hand
side or on the right hand side to
compute that area
and then the trapezoidal rule is
averaging them it's averaging the left
hand and the right hand area rules okay
okay there's also these nice uh built-in
python functions okay so uh let's just
run this
these built-in python functions you can
just use the sum of this that's the left
rectangle rule the sum of this on the
right that's the right rectangle rule or
the Trap Z is the trapezoid that's area
one area two area three
and I think that's you know this one
this one and this one
uh
yeah and this one these are actually
much closer to the values and they're
different than these so I think
something's something's wrong up here I
I can't obviously see it off the top of
my head but there's something I think
wrong up here
okay so we're going to try to estimate
the area of a function
uh using these different rules in Matlab
and uh let's let's just go to the very
top so what we're going to do is we're
going to Define our sine function on an
interval 0 to 10 A to B and we're
defining this fine resolution Delta x a
very small Delta X basically just to
plot my sine function so you can see a
nice clean version and then a really
coarse big Delta X of 0.5 to show kind
of the sampling that we're going to use
for these these rules
um and I think what I'm going to do is
just plot to begin with
okay so this kind of shows the the sine
function in Orange and then these blue
uh ladders this is I guess the left
rectangle Rule and so the sum of these
left rectangles would be my left
rectangle approximation so you can see
it's a pretty bad uh a pretty bad
course representation
and I can compute my left rectangle rule
by adding up all of my my left points
times Delta X I can compute my right
rectangle rule by adding up all of my
right points times Delta X and the
trapezoid is just the average of those
two
um you can use the built-in Matlab
commands just you know some over all the
left points up until n minus one or some
over all the right points from two index
two to the end or trap Z is this really
nice you know built-in trapezoidal rule
you can do that as well and you can
either give it a list of X locations XC
or you cannot give it a list of X and
it'll assume unit spacing and then you
have to multiply by Delta X
and then finally these area F's are the
fine resolution approximations using
that fine grid that we were using for
plotting so I'm just going to run all of
this all at once
K and area 3F that was one of the fine
ones
1.8391 I'm just going to write that up
1.8391 and so now we're going to compare
okay uh area one was left rectangle area
two was right rectangle and area three
was trapezoidal rule and so you can see
that area one is overshooting area two
is undershooting and area three the
trapezoid rule is almost you know it's
definitely the closest to the area using
a very very small Delta X okay so this
kind of just shows that our our left and
right rectangles are less accurate are
trapezoid even for a very coarse Delta X
of 0.5 is much much closer to the True
Value if I used a teeny tiny Delta X
okay so that just kind of shows how to
code these up and how to assess the
error okay
um that's everything I wanted to show
you numerical integration so that's it
for today thank you
[Music]